oh hi reject nation yeah you're there
perhaps it's not a bad guess
oh hi resignation Oh eros in the room
once and the best artist once you've
seen the room so many times you have it
in your ear better I'll get it when I
watch on one on your honor way
oh hi job it just makes me so giddy that
you're doing like that makes my day
better every time you do this was like a
passion film Oh your YouTube telling
about this movie for like over a decade
yeah ma'am my dad brought this home
here's the killer family yeah you go to
the theaters throw spoons and all these
things how you doing welcome to the
reject nation my friend really quick I
wanted to say a quick thank you to
everyone over at patreon you guys have
been so fantastic and we just got out of
a Google hangout with uh not to be
derogatory or andorran just have me
thinking so much about how grateful I am
for all you guys over at patreon every
post exclusive daily content over there
in case you guys that you know and we
have a bunch of other extra perks that
we do as well and everything of course
goes back to helping out the channel
loops and pay it's just so much more
it's a different environment over there
and I really do I really do you love it
you don't get haters over a patron like
I paid five bucks to tell you to kill
yourself especially nice to shoot a
disaster artist review after doing
patreon stuff because it gets you to
think about like you know not everyone
will love what you do but you character
those people at patreon really gets you
to feel like these are the people that
really welcome people will really care
care about it yeah I mean if you're not
part of the patron doesn't mean I don't
think you don't love what we do
yeah just saying it got me all
sentimental this movie has a weird
effect now is the longest intro into it
movie we've ever done man - Greta -
attitude of gratitude so we actually saw
the room a few days ago Jon show them
your jacket go that's why you're wearing
show them your jacket you can tell from
the bend over like a girl yeah there you
go
yep Jon's a room fan Tommy Wiseau likes
to wear his nice clothes so I figured
out where what I wore to the movie
premiere yeah thanks Ryan Fonz Oh
SDX entertainment for sending that to
the connotation of their Manas was total
blast to go there on to this movie I saw
the room for the first time here I enjoy
it actually I was worried it might be
annoying yeah and then I watched it and
I was laughing at all the all the right
spots apparently because I didn't know
any of the movie then going into the
disaster artist I had a lot of intrigue
into seeing this because that movie
Tommy Wiseau is so known for his voice
his mannerisms I just given a really bad
performances okay you know so that was
curious because everyone's like praising
James Franco's performance in this movie
and I'm like it's it's him doing a role
about a terrible actor but he has to be
real when we're so used to seeing him do
a bad job he's got to embody a very
specific guy who would be very easy to
make cartoon and make it just an
imitation right off the bat for even
reviewing what this movie is James
Franco Denis oh dude he like Hills it he
he was the perfect out how he was funny
and has historical did everything we
wanted then also gave us like scenes
were he's kind of scary here he's kind
of he's pretty emotional here you know I
feel like he'd kind of embodies that
same spirit of the room where you're
like yeah what this is a really weird
performance of a really weird guy yeah
somehow it feels completely authentic
okay so this movie is essentially about
the making of the room yeah the 2003
cult hit that he just keeps getting
bigger and bigger it's the only movie I
think in LA that still plays at a
theater yeah it never left or you know
maybe for a little bit this movie you're
seeing the creation process and seem and
it's based on based on the book that
Greg Sestero who co-starred in the room
wrote basically about their friendship
and how they met and how this all came
to be oh I didn't know that yes sir
co-wrote that book this movie focuses on
Tommy Wiseau and Greg Sestero that's the
whole heart of the movie you might go
into it just wanting to see the behind
the scenes of the room film and then you
realize there's actually a buddy movie
this is a bestfriend movie about people
with dreams in hopes and ambitions who
are going for it who are really going
for making that move to Los Angeles
where excist arrow is this young guy
played by dave Franco for
tell me why so we don't know where he's
from we don't know what age he is we
don't know how he has money and to this
day we have no idea yeah no one know
he's a mystery it could be anything you
can't quite pinpoint it James Franco as
a director it's like no one's really
praising his direction enough in this
film he didn't write the film but I
really feel like this really depends on
the direction of the movie he strikes a
perfect balance a perfect tone you know
you see the room it's cheesy it's funny
you want this movie to be funny because
it's say you know biopic of this
specific story you wanted to also have
moments of drama and realism and to
enlighten you as to what reopened but
you don't want it to get too funny where
it doesn't feel realistic and you don't
want to get too serious where you lose
that fun of what made the room so
special yeah and he finds that he nails
it he nails it yeah his the direction I
don't know how this guy put this movie
together give you frickin performance
and directs this movie that is perfectly
balanced in its tone just like Tommy
Wiseau did
yeah the exact flip I really feel like
this is a great companion piece to the
room it is because this in no way
exposing the corruption of what the room
it's not that movie it's a movie that
actually makes you appreciate the [ __ ]
out of the room a million times more
yeah yeah and how strange that process
must have been and like regardless of
who what anybody thought about it
everybody was just trying to make it
happen yeah I think that's one of the
best things about it is that it does
function as a companion piece like it it
does kind of depend on you having seen
the room to fully assess one fault
although we are meeting people that have
seen the disaster artist without haven't
seen the room and still love this movie
I personally feel that you will love it
if you watch the room you'll feel the
magic I think yeah I don't know what's
truly magical about what they did with
this
I really think you can watch the room
and then watch this right after I think
yeah and that's that companions way yeah
it's a bit a better movie with more
professional everything but somehow it
feels it has an uncanny balance of being
an actual film but kind of still in the
magical world of the way I know because
room is a very specific place you go you
have good time your bedtime you express
yourself but don't hurt and you know and
also in terms of his direction I loved
his choice to make it handheld the room
is not handheld it is shot a very
specific way by making it handheld it
does two things one it brings you into
this is the real world two it allows you
to discern even better and stronger the
images of the room it makes it even more
of a good companion piece of yeah cuz
you almost feel like you're there
especially when it's like you know what
the room looks like and then you see
them on set in your leg so they're
making a different looking film in the
film yeah it makes you feel even more
fly-on-the-wall about it yeah which is a
thing that pulls you into this movie for
sure and I gotta imagine it's it would
be kind of easy to wrangle that as a
first-time director yeah yeah just you
know kind of stick over here and then
we're gonna work the scene out here I'll
tell you guys in a year where you got
some great films like get out split and
Wonder Woman Logan and more many more
this is actually the only film it's been
a few days since we've seen it and we're
shooting this review now and I'm
actually pretty glad we are because my
statement stands true it's it's sunk in
yeah it's sunk in and I'm still been
thinking about it yeah the things I've
been thinking about it like I've
consistently been thinking about it and
he keeps popping into my head and it's
that rare feeling where I keep lingering
on and thinking about it because as much
as I love a lot of other movies this is
the only one I'm still thinking about
this usually makes my list for one of
the best films of the year yeah I was
thoroughly surprised by how much I
adored it yeah listen get out both
definitely like stuck with me four times
it's a really well-balanced moving it
doesn't outstay its welcome either which
is a good thing because that's another
that's a that's a choice on James
Franco's and it's kind of as long as the
room is I think yeah and in a way it's
like they it has this sort of Boogie
Nights Ness about it where you know you
watch the the rise and here's how we're
gonna we're gonna do it and then you
know you see how things can get sour and
stuff like that but it doesn't draw out
super far it keeps a steady pace the
whole time you know one thing that we
were predicting in the trailers and then
we walk out still saying this to is how
this sort of feels like our generations
Atwood
even though Edward is our generation
it's definitely different
ed wood really capitalizes on failure
and it even ends in a way for your luck
yeah this guy had a [ __ ] life what I
love about this film and I feel like the
best way to tell you especially what I
found so appreciative about this movie
is by comparing it to Ed Wood because Ed
Wood leaves me with a feeling of oh my
god I hope I don't end up like this guy
one day as opposed to the disaster
artist where it inspires you I felt
inspired I felt hopeful I felt like you
know what it's totally ok to just go for
your dreams and make what you want to
make ed what does not let Ed Wood see
what becomes a plan 9 from outer space
yeah here they show it in the trailers
order they go to the premiere and
everything like that and they're
watching the movie you get to see the
effect that the room has and you get to
see why it's a special film it left me
with a feeling of don't be afraid to
dream and still make what you want to
make even if it ends out a certain way
you have no idea how people might
respond yeah you have no idea what that
could become even if it's not exactly
what you had and it's Trippier to watch
it in a theater where tommy was oh and
Greg Sestero
are there and are currently planning
other stuff to do in a weird way it
works like yeah you made it work you
know somehow you now have that I think
that's that's also fundamental
differences like Tommy Wiseau has a
little Empire going like he's really
making it work whereas Ed Wood after a
while hey we gotta meet Tommy wise oh
yeah yeah that's cool that was great you
have to touch him like it's weird like a
lot of people wrought the premiere I
don't approach a lot of people even if I
have access to everybody so was the one
guy where I was like if there's one
person I have to just suck up and go
through it go up to him and say hi it
was Tommy wise number that was the one
where I was like he's the one I want to
say hi to you Estero dave Franco yeah
really great in the film too I felt like
the first half of the film he was kind
of doing a Tom Cruise thing yeah he was
really like plucky affable guy yeah yeah
I've always bashful smiles but he is a
multi-layered
formants they did something incredible
which you know these guys are brothers
but when you're watching the movie all
you see is yeah Greg Sestero and Tommy
Wiseau and you see best friends and it's
a very different dynamic and bond that
what brothers are I have a brother and I
have a best friend and I volved we're
very different dynamics and in that
movie you're like yeah that's that's the
best best friend yeah Tori right there
I'm so happy to watch this is I feel
like that movie especially for us this
was like that's the movie which one's
Tommy which was great yeah I love this
film there's some great supporting
performances clear tons of PBS too many
to list to 2 million I mean Seth Rogen's
great in it who's the DP Paul Scheer
Paul shooter he's fantastic as well
these are like the main ones they're
really funny and they come and late into
the film because he know it's like
halfway through you start really seeing
them all the people who work on the
movie is like a revolving door of
comedians you know if there was only a
couple of criticisms I'd give the film
first criticism was I kind of wish they
got to them making the room a little
faster see I don't know I feel like that
would play differently a second viewing
that's what you came there to see yeah
that you're like I want to get to that I
was anxious so I feel like the second
time around I could just sit back and
really just be completely invested and
enjoy it's like I was enjoying it
absolutely I just didn't feel like I
start really truly loving it until we
got to the parts of the room when I feel
like it's because of anticipation I feel
like a lot of people in the first
viewing might have to get used to it for
a second yeah and then it kind of
redirects your expectations a little bit
in a way that's cool and surprising see
how like by the time you're at the end
you're like I get it now and then yeah
second viewing might might work a little
better the other criticism I have is the
female characters I'm not the cutest
movie in any shape or form of being
sexist this films spanning a lot and and
so it doesn't feel over overdone it
focuses on the main characters that are
required to really focus on which are
the DP the script supervisor Seth
Rogen's character and Seth Rogen and
dave Franco those are the main ones you
have to keep the attention on then you
have like Alison Brie's character
there's your name Franco's girlfriend
and then you have the woman who played
Lisa in the room
with grandmother - the woman who plays
your grandmother yeah and especially the
one who plays Lisa I felt like she
should have had more yes drink time were
allowed and something tells me there's
deleted scenes I feel like she could
have used a scene that focused on her
beyond the one scene that is not because
she's just kind of a Kyrgyz like okay
okay okay that's like yeah okay I'll do
it okay that's it but where you can see
there's more to that character that's
only one of the couple things I found
that I wanted to see more abut I really
get the impression there's a deleted
scene there he a deleted scenes there's
clearly a lot of improv that happens in
this movie and I thought they could have
fleshed out some of the supporting actor
characters more beyond just her like
Josh Hutcherson is character yeah I
could have used like a couple character
moments of like oh we're not shooting
right now with you guys yeah I get why
there might not be just because of how
the perspective of the disaster artist
yeah it's all from Greg's perspective
it's all from Greg and Tommy's
perspective yeah that's really great
yeah Tommy like you're always gonna be a
visitor on planet yeah always gonna be a
little on the outside either way with
sizes couple of criticisms and I get
this movie a solid 5 out of 5 stars
yeah I love the crap out of this movie
it's really yeah this is unique and I
feel like it works both ways
yeah I feel like the next step for James
Franco now is to master his own visual
style yeah clearly he can put together a
film make a fine tone he can direct
actors really well now the next step is
like what's his look alright reject
nation well thanks for tuning in to our
review a once again thank you to
everyone over at patreon if you ever
become a patron and become a patronage
act today I'm telling us follow us on
Stardust always in the Stardust app man
it just passed a thousand followers and
we were loving using that app it's like
a great app to just like I saw this
movie called barefoot in York or
barefoot in the park and I'm like I
can't post a review this who the hell is
gonna watch it yeah I got like the
in-between stuff for the Indies or even
episodes it's yeah yeah a great place a
great place for that and so you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification about and follow us on
social media but mainly start us
maitreya take care people